on va jouer tout de suite tous ensemble
pour signer votre contrat cass au
cache-cache confrères c'est bon on a
caché vos contrats contemporain haïtien
ce soir vous allez partir à deux à
chaque fois on a caché vos contrats dans
le hall
d'accord les chérit le premier qui me
ramène son contrat bibliographie même
hallyday va valider va valider les
valides et les attentions
retour attention aux blessés trois sont
des gens ça peut être partout mais un
dance central crois qu'il est dans une
jarre otakia non non pas du tout [ __ ]
c'est la normale
non ici j'en ai quoi t'as quoi dedans
c'est pas toi et regarde des vérités
blacks c'est votre contrat doit alors
on va voir si ça lui chante au contrat
y'a rien n'entrave et là les mots
attention vous est donné mais
malheureusement pour l'instant benhaim
regarder la société c'est un vrai ballet
ces cons ils ont fait l'erreur de ne
faut pas c'est pas possible
à l'essai du shérif allez vite en tout
cas elles vont vite en d2 je n'y ai
jamais vis-à-vis a voulu punir qui
trouve son contrat est ce que ça va être
les abeilles s'organise on cherchait pas
tout partout ça peut même être une
personne ah ouais bah matures une
personne nationale et notre attention et
nous avions bien il est oui ou non plus
rien lâcher pour voiture une personne ça
peut être également dans une plante dans
une plante réception
[Applaudissements]
paris
isabelle morini bosc
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est bon on la retrouvera dans deux ans
ses ministres tiennent par la main molle
alors les beaux phone etes vous toujours
à la voile et bouffonne à laissé dix
voix et nora et agathe la gagne et bâle
a gagné merci pour les cadres arbitres à
gâteau proulx malaga et non
malheureusement ma chère y aura d'autres
occasions te plait pas je peux pas je
prie dieu
attention faiblesse
ils ont baissé ils ont dû laisser sa
marque forcément pensé qu'on pouvait
accrocher lula ouais mec moi même c'est
là quand je regardais de retrouver son
contrat le plus vite et le jean michel
prêtre
allez j'en dis oui
[Rires]
la mousse à raser
[Applaudissements]
gilles verdez j'ai mal un contre un
gilles verdez racontera et est validé
bravo malheureusement j'ai envie chaleur
on n'a plus de nouvelles